quelques divisions chez les LR et
notamment une sorte de fronde emmenée
par le député LR Aurélien pragique il
dit pour l'instant moi je ne vote pas
cette réforme des retraites en l'état
car je la trouve injuste et d'ailleurs
il interpelle il vous interpelle en
disant attention de votez pas une
réforme injuste qu'est-ce que vous leur
répondez Bruno je pense qu'il se trompe
il se trompe peut-être aussi de famille
politique nous on n'est pas la gauche on
est la droite notre ADN ça a toujours
été le courage la vérité et la vérité
c'est dire aux Français pas peut-être ce
qu'ils veulent absolument entendre mais
que si on ne fait rien parce que on a de
plus en plus de retraités de moins en
moins de jeunes de cotisants parce que
sur 10 ans on va accumuler plus de 150
milliards d'euros et bien on va mettre
en l'air notre modèle social voilà je
pense que cette réforme elle est
perfectible mais très franchement je ne
comprends pas qu'il y a encore deux mois
il réclamait 45 à nuités et que
maintenant il est passé à 43 où est la
cohérence où est la logique je pense que
au bout du compte en 2030 quand la
réforme va s'appliquer on sera le pays
d'Europe de toute l'Europe qui partira
le plus tôt en retraite le pays d'Europe
où on aura les carrières langues les
plus généreuses la pénibilité aussi le
mieux prise en compte ça oui et moi je
me suis battu pour les petites retraites
je me battrai aussi pour les maires de
famille est-ce que vous avez le
sentiment coréen Pradier en train de
jouer une carte personnelle finalement
dans ce débat de faire entendre sa
petite musique bien sûr bien sûr je
pense que on peut évidemment avoir des
différences mais je crois que cette
surenchère cache cette idée à la fois
qu'il faut détruire en tout cas trouer
de toute part la réforme qui te sera
plus une réforme parce que si elle ne
produit pas les marges de manœuvre
escomptées on sera en 2030 non pas
l'équilibre ou voir un excédent on sera
à nouveau en déficit et il faudra
prendre des mesures encore plus fortes
vous craignez cette douzaine de députés
républicains qui pour l'instant sont
opposés à la réforme non non je pense et
je fais le pari d'ailleurs ça concerne
Aurélien Pradier que après cette
scénographie il va ce texte
s'il le vote pas ça posera un énorme
problème pour notre famille politique il
devrait être exclu de cette famille
politique non mais je pense que
vis-à-vis de l'équipe dirigeante ça
posera vraiment un vrai souci
[Musique]